anyone else i would like to contribute
hi hi i'm ann perkins uh i'm a nurse and
frankly i don't really care for
politics but um i'm i'm here to talk
about the abandoned lot on sullivan
street excellent that sounds like a good
idea tell us about that no it's a
problem it almost killed my boyfriend oh
yeah there's a lot nearby my house and a
developer dug out a basement for some
condos and then they went bankrupt so
there's just this giant pit
and it's been there for almost a year 12
months yes go on yeah and my boyfriend
who is a musician actually i support him
but anyway
he fell in and broke both his legs so um
andy
jumped over this fence he was crossing
through to get home and then he fell
right there
oh my god how do we let this happen
dream with me for a second anne doesn't
this neighborhood deserve a first-class
park
imagine a shiny new playground with
jungle gym and swings school tennis
courts volleyball courts racquetball
courts basketball court regulation
football field we could put an
amphitheater over there with shakespeare
in the park it's really not that big of
a pit you could do some of those things
it's gonna take a little extra work
but why not try
i think that would be great
me too
i'm going in
why don't worry i have a hard out on i
could see that but yeah april document
this that can't work key to any
fact-finding mission is to get right
into the battle zone you know
it's like george bush when he flew over
new orleans or richard nixon when he
went to china to see what the chinese
were up to no oh oh oh oh
oh
leslie are you okay
leslie hold on april's gonna get some
photos for the website can you just be
still don't move around as much
no no wait what am i doing
this isn't the way i want this to happen
again
leslie it's not that big a deal
i think you should go homework
all right
okay
i'm sorry that's uh
i'm gonna get out of here yeah i'm sorry
it's okay
no oh my god oh
oh my god oh my god mark are you all
right wow
are you okay
oh my god
go get some help help go get some help
hey babe
baby open up
that guy mark just fell in the pit oh
gotta get back to the office
have a good one
the hardest part about living in this
pit
is probably keeping my suit pressed
and the rats
it's like a freaking rat parade every
night
i just want to be close to her house
because i need to protect her because
there are some weird people that live
around here
is that andy
andy
i know you're in there because i can see
you through the screen
and
hey what's up
what are you doing
do you live down here
what
what yes
oh my god
uh oh my god you live down here oh my
god i can't believe this is happening
what i i can't be at my house and see my
ex-boyfriend living in a hole in my
backyard like a gopher that's so weird
andy listen i've i have been trying
really hard not to bother you like when
you had that barbecue last week i didn't
come up even though it smelled so good
you've been here a whole week yes
one week only
oh i guess i guess it's the office you
were telling me about that you go to
work to every day excellent listen are
we gonna talk about anything other than
the lies that i told you oh i can't do
this right now i have a guy fixing my
bathroom i gotta go i
that's cool i gotta zoom out too cause i
have some people coming over so watch
call first next time
you know the way out oh
oh this is one of my greatest
brainstorms ever a community garden
right in the middle of the pit
we're encouraging people to just come
out and plant whatever they want and tom
and i sometimes get here early and help
out
it's so hot i had to get some more iced
tea
people have just really embraced this
and planted the coolest stuff and tom is
our master of horticulturist he knows
all the scientific names for everything
right tom yup like this what's this tom
um those are of course tomatoes or
soulja boy tellers whenever leslie asked
me for the latin names of any of our
plants i just gave her the names of
rappers
and those over there
uh those are some diddies got some uh
bone thugs and harmoniums right here
growing beautifully those ludicrouses
are coming in great look someone planted
something new what's
this what do you think carrots if that's
true we have a garden past on our hands
maybe some kind of spice yeah you know
leslie the best way to figure out what
kind of spice that is is roll it up into
a joint and smoke it
in there
[Music]
you were
[Applause]
is this
living out my dream playing a show with
the greatest band ever
that's my guitar you bought it back from
sewage joe
i actually stole it from his office
but whatever he's a weirdo
maybe april doesn't think that we're the
greatest band in the world but man
she loves me
and i love her so you know who cares
i got the greatest wife in the world
[Applause]
we're totally gonna do it later
you